Have a president who really is from the people who says,
uh,
he looks at like,
you know,
here's eight folders of stuff to read.
And like,
I don't think so.
Give me the cliff notes.
Like I'll play it from the hip.
Like,
no,
I'm going to watch Fox and friends.
You tell me what I needed to know.
And you know,
it's not for me to sit and rip on the guy because he's not here to defend
himself,
but never in my life have I ever watched an American president thought to
myself,
I could have done better in that situation.
And there's presidents,
I've had nothing but disagree with,
but they were way better for the job than I ever could be.
I look at this guy and I'm like,
man,
you just got played and there's something,
when I knew I was going to be talking to you,
there's a thing I was thinking about.
Um,
cause I,
I saw,
I heard you speak many years ago about these politicians are gangster.
He said like,
okay,
what that guy did that's Gangsta and what this guy just did straight up
gangsters during the Bush administration.
You are just,
I think it was like Halliburton,
all these people,
the Cheney world and you're like,
that's a gangster movie.
That's a gangster movie.
I'm like,
I can't disagree with anything he just said.
And on that kind of level,
I think what I never hear is that Donald Trump is a guy who gets consistently
played,
rolled,
got rolled by his wife,
who a woman I have nothing against,
but she comes from a really tough part of the world.
Slovenia,
that's just a rough patch or real estate.
She's smart and she's tough and she got out,
got to America,
well he's not much on looks but it's a way in from the storm.
So he got played by his wife.
He got played by Paul Manafort.
He got played by Kim Jong Un.
He got played like Jimi Hendrix at Monterey that that particular stratocaster by
Vladimir Putin and gets played like rock modern off every single day and anyone
he does high stakes business with or renegotiations he gets played,
played and,
and Manafort just used him to try and,
you know,
get out of debt and all these other people,
they just roll all over him.
And unfortunately his Hubris is such,
he's like ha ha,
like no dude,
you just got blown out and like everyone around you is playing you.
Well he probably doesn't feel that way with Manafort because Manafort's on trial
and he's not yet right,
but Manafort played him cause Manafort really does play in that world of
oligarchs and millions of dollars in laundering money.
If he wrote a book,
I was telling someone the other day as I have all these people,
he should write the book because it would be a page Turner if he told the truth
would get him killed.
He touched the wrong door knob and he gets poisoned.
Cause like Simon Putin can't have him telling what he knows.
He's a man.
He probably will go to prison,
watch him have some kind of strange accident.
He was liquefied in the shower.
Something about the water because he knows a lot and there's a lot of people who
can pay a lot of money to keep his mouth shut.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what's fascinating to me is that over the last year or two,
especially from the Fox crew,
you're seeing Vladimir Putin admired.
Yup.
It's very strange.
I never thought we would see that.
I was watching,
uh,
something a couple of years ago at a year ago and I was like,
some guy,
well,
he's a good Christian man and he believes in family.
I'm like,
he's the butcher of Chechnya.
Yeah.
Let's flash back to the 1960s.
I'm a young boy on the weekend visit with my father to the right of my father is
a wall.
There's nothing to the right of my father,
just nothing.
And um,
if he's still with us,
he'd be in his nineties and hard as a rock,
just like nothing.
He's like a bar of Hickory.
Anyway.
Um,
he's an economist.
He's a numbers guy and a phd,
rural,
smart.
I'm coming home to my mom's apartment from the Saturday,
Sunday visit with dad.
We're in Washington DC area.
I'm a little boy,
five years old,
somewhere around there.
Very small economist and Communist.
I don't know what either of them are arguably to a five year old kind of sounds
the same.
I'm in the big Buick station wagon,
um,
to my father's right.
We're pulling up to mom's apartment.
Henry Dad,
are you a communist?
I don't think my father's facial expression changed.
His right hand came off the wheel and his backhand collided with my head.
It was just like,
I hear the word common is a boy gets smacked and it was without hatred or
violence.
It was like national security,
like whack.
He didn't even know he did it.
He was like a sneeze,
like Kapow and it hurts so much.
My head went numb and it was not even the pain.
It was like the shock of uh,
your dad whacking you with,
you had no idea what you did and all I could do,
it was hyper ventilate and he opened the door and he let me out.
He didn't say a word,
he didn't tell you that there's a difference between a communist and an
economist.
So I left the call like for like till I was like 33,
you know what I mean?
Cause it's so destabilizing.
Like your dad just walloped you and I get out of the elevator,
I go into the apartment,
the smoke.
But I did that till I was like,
you know,
till two years ago.
It was totally,
she said,
honey,
what happened?
I said,
I asked dad if he was a comic.
She's like,
okay,
well the point I'm making is this.
There's a bunch of people who voted for Trump.
Were you say Russia?
They say bunch of sons of bitches.
Trust him as far as you can throw your car.
Are you kidding?
And when I see staunch conservative Republicans going,
well,
that boot and guy,
I'm like,
are you kidding people like my dad's heads are exploding.
He's an old Cold War Guy.
We would wash,
uh,
Boris and Natasha,
whatever that cartoon was as,
yeah,
as a kid,
I'm laughing cause the guy with,
ah,
my dad's laughing on a whole other level because it's Cold War funnies.
It's was written for the parents.
The kids get the cartoon,
the parents got the jokes that that was for adults Wa with their kids on
Saturday.
You watch them later on,
you're like,
oh,
this is cold war humor.
I wouldn't have known,
but that's my dad's world.
You say Russia,
he probably hated my guts because I've been there six times for shows and to
take the Trans Siberian express.
And so this warming up to a guy who is a true bad guy,
he's scary.
There's bodies buried because of him.
He's one of the scariest guys on the planet.
[inaudible] and capably violent and we'll have you taken out,
I mean like Anna Politkovskaya,
one of the greatest journalists of our time.
She was critical of Putin and she got assassinated in her apartment building.
Her books are great.
Her books from Chechnya are amazing.
And like he was,
she was critical of him and she had to go.
And when you see our president cozying up to this guy,
I just want to go,
Bro,
let's talk play.
Let's take a walk in the garden for 20 minutes.
You can't be friends with this guy.
My theory is there,
there,
there's,
there's some kind of finances where he's,
he's got a stick up for him.
I don't think it's a tape of people urinating on anyone.
I think it's his money too cliche to interesting.
Um,
it,
it's,
it's a,
it's a money thing.
It's a hotel deal.
It's money sitting in Cypress.
It's something.
But the fact that we're being,
becoming okay with this guy,
that is the part that bugs me the most and why people in Congress or collect
Sean Hannity who like probably likes Communists as much as my dad,
even me.
I don't trust people like that at all.
Putin is a criminal,
should be in jail for a million,
billion years.
And the fact that gay,
he's,
uh,
like when,
when he's a strong leader,
he,
he's a,
he's a human being.
We can talk like,
gosh,
he's like x Kgb guy who,
and there's no such thing as an ex KGB guy,
right?
Yeah.
They're KGB for life,
for life.
And he's a supreme operative.
And what he does is he,
he rolls people like you dude,
and like cut you are a guppy.
He's a shark.
Like no two guys hanging out.
No one guy getting played in one guy playing someone.
I think he admires the fact that Putin is able to run his country the way he
does too.
Yes.
And that's why he looks Duterte and [inaudible] and I've been to,
we said about,
Ooh,
and he said he's a strong head and I,
those countries,
I've been to the Philippines,
I've been to North Korea.
They're tough places to live and like you don't want your country looking like
those places.
You don't want America to be like Russia.
It,
the economy's destroyed and there's a lot of people like in the wintertime it's
really tough.
How do you think the seniors homeless thing?
He goes to jail?
No,
no.
Uh,
because I don't believe in Karma.
Karma.
Here's my two words that disprove Karma.
Dick Cheney,
he's got a new heart and a new heart.
He has no pulse,
which is perfectly,
he's got a pulse now with the new heart.
Okay.
Cause the machine,
yeah.
Knew Paul Sheen,
he just heard a wish,
which is perfect for him.
But a Bible,
he may very well live cause he looked like he's watching his weight now.
He's like look and lean.
He might live to be like 105.
Um,
and so he'll never go to jail and,
and like how many millions does he make a year?
Just from his dividends,
from whatever.
Like who knows what you do with that kind of money?
I don't know what you do with it.
And so I don't think he goes to jail.
I don't think Jared Cushner goes to jail.
I think it most,
they leave like maybe next year and they go like,
I drained the swamp.
I did what I came here to do and the fake news media brought me down and all his
people buy one of everything.
He makes forever steak vodka.
I think it's possible that Donald Trump jr goes to jail.
It's very possible they're talking about perjury charges against him now because
his own dad admitted on Twitter.
Yes.
Yeah,
no,
I follow all that stuff.
As you know,
I just don't think white collar guys go to prison for stuff.
I just don't believe it.
You know,
I want to be proven wrong,
but I don't have all the facts.
I'm a,
I'm a news watcher.
I know nothing.
I don't get any classified briefs so I only know what I read and what I hear.
Talking about any of this stuff and your stay jacked a little bit,
but knowing my audience,
they're very sharp and they read the readers and they don't need me repeating
what they know that to them.
And so,
well good for you for that.
If I make a point,
as my dad used to say,
you want to score hidden where they ain't the baseball idea.
And so if I can make a point,
like if I was on stage tonight,
I talking about Trump,
I would roll out that idea of Trump is a guy who has been played by so many
people around him and no one talks about his wife playing him.
Like there's no love in that marriage.
I don't think she saw a way out,
came to New York and went,
that guy,
yeah,
gets naked with the toad a few nights a month,
handful of a handful of Prozac,
some Stoli and a credit card and a seven figure expense account.
You can take a shower and make it go away.
Um,
so I,
I think he,
and I think he kind of knows that,
you know,
she was not like,
wow,
what a hot guy.
She's like,
Hey,
and there's,
you know,
that happens a lot in this town.
You'll see that yield the couple,
and you're like,
okay.
Yeah,
right.
Well,
Harvey Weinstein before his,
uh,
for his wife left him Harvey Weinstein's wife was beautiful.
Well,
yeah,
but you see that a lot in this town where you see the,
the old weird dude with like the,
the eight year old girlfriend,
you're like,
oh yeah,
that's a,
that's a setup.
That's an agency.
That's an agreement.
That's someone's getting a salary or an implied,
you know,
it's,
it's uh,
there's some kind of quid pro quo.
There's a credit card,
there's an expense account or there's just like a big fist full of hundreds and
just let me chew on you for the next four weeks or whatever the agreement is.
And,
and I,
so if I was going to say anything about Donald Trump on stage would be who soaks
I never talk about any problem onstage.
And I learned this from,
of all people,
President Clinton,
because some of his later speeches post-presidency I'm not a huge fan of the
guy,
but he's a good speaker.
And he did some speeches in the UK a few years ago and I happened to be in
England when he was there and I watched him on TV.
The last part of this huge,
the last 10 minutes was,
here's a problem and here's three solutions.
Here's another problem.
Here's three solutions.
We're like for for $60 million.
We could put Internet through this thing or we could open this waterway or we
could reconfigure this workforce to upgrade so everyone can get a paycheck.
He just had logical ways forward.
So what I took from that is to my audience,
don't propose a problem.
Well he sucks.
Thanks.
Good night.
Don't give them a Gordian knot unless you can go.
Actually,
it's not a Gordian knot.
Here's three ways to get out of this burning wreck.
And so like when,
when Trump became elected,
it was,
I was on tour,
I was doing a bunch of nights in La and I said,
okay,
you have a new president and some of you are depressed.
I said,
I know.
And so gay people are on the endangered species list is as if they've never
been.
Um,
Brown people,
black people,
women,
people,
people with ovaries.
These were all on the you're screwed list.
So instead of being coming depressed and oh no,
let's we get up,
we started doing more benefits.
Now all your words matter.
Your actions matter.
How you stick up for your LGBT friends really matters.
Now,
how you stick up for women,
how you stick up for racial equality,
equality in the workplace,
like a,
how you check yourself when you really do with other people.
Words matter.
Actions matter more than ever.
And so to me,
it's an exciting time to show how great you can be because now it's all on the
line.
The fat is off the land.
We're being tested.
I love a test.
So let's get it on.
It's like a in your line of work when the guy goes,
here we go.
That's how I saw it.
Like,
okay,
let's read.
Let's get the Monday to the ACL.
Aclu.
Let's get some money to planned parenthood.
Let's get a conversation going about a child suicide,
intimidation through Facebook.
Let's start making things better because this guy is not our ally.
Governments not necessarily going to help at its best.
It's inactive at its worst.
It's divisive and predatory.
So let's be the antidote by being cool.
Bye.
You're not throwing rocks through windows or like getting it out of the Tiki
torch and beating him up.
C'Mon,
um,
you're never going to convince that guy that he's wrong.
So get to the people you agree with and let's start sticking together more and
raising more money and get some more interesting people in office.
And let's get some young people in office.
And I think that's what's happening.
Like you're seeing all these young people like twenties thirties,
sadly,
there's a bunch of kids who died at a high school in Florida.
But look what happened.
Look at all those kids hitting the streets.
Look at all these kids who through cell phones and selfies and Instagram and
snapchat,
they're already ready for primetime.
You see these high school juniors in front of us,
CNN,
camera going,
hi,
I'm 17 years old.
This happened to my school,
and next year I'm going to vote and here's what's going to happen and here's the
march I'm starting.
I'm like,
oh,
that's a future senator.
You just,
that school shooting just birthed a voting demographic.
Are you kidding?
All those kids are going to vote.
All of them,
all those kids who marched,
there's going to be no millennial apathy with those kids.
They're all going to vote.
I kind of have an idea what side they're going to vote with,
and if you think you're going to sell those kids on their grandfather's drunk
and homophobia,
racism and his overall bigotry and xenophobia,
you're wrong.
He never had a pass where,
I don't need to travel.
I don't want to meet some damn Mexican.
Trust me.
The kids going to travel,
he's going to go to India.
She's going to go to Columbia and meet other people and get a more global sense
of the world,
a sense of water,
food,
energy,
where it comes from,
where what happens with money,
what happens with mediocrity,
the danger of it.
So I think we're in for some tough times,
but I think they're going to lead to good times.
And so that's what if I get political on stage,
all I say is like,
here's five ways forward because the despair part you like,
you need me to tell you,
you watch the news.
So don't get down in the mouth,
start burning more calories and that,
and that's
not my job.
But I would never weigh in on stage any other way about that stuff.
Cause all I would be as obvious and my audience is pretty sharp and they don't
need to be told twice.
Outstanding.
Thank you sir.
Well said.
I couldn't agree more.